Wir sind so richtig vorm Salon, im Salon. Ja, heute sind wir in Frankfurt live.
Das Publikum hat schon Platz genommen.
Und wir haben uns ja schon ein bisschen unterhalten und freuen uns, dass auch so viele von weiter her angereist sind.
Lübeck war dabei, Bremen, Augsburg, München.
Alle, ja. Sehr beeindruckend. Also eigentlich müssen wir ja schon einen Preis von der Stadt bekommen, dass wir den Tourismus hier so stärken.
Ja, wir sind ein Reisepodcast. Die Hörer kommen reisen für uns.
Okay, worüber reden wir gleich? wir gleich wir werden jetzt gleich erst einmal ein bisschen über tschetschewi t
sprechen und über tiktok glämmer wie kann man sein gesicht perfektionieren
digital werden wir weinen was zu tränen gerührt sein wenn ich mein junges ich
sehe wer weiß wir gehen dann über zu einer doku über ja klimarettung im
regionalen aber promis wollen dieses klima retten das war sehr viel Versprechend immer.
Anker Ingeke, Aurel Merz. Ich glaube, es wird viel zu lachen und zu schimpfen gehen.
Okay, lass aber nur Obama ab. Wir wollen ja da nochmal richtig schimpfen.
Wir wollen da nochmal richtig schimpfen, gehen dann über zum Thema Hass.
Seda Kurt plädiert ja dafür, dass man strategisch hassen sollte.
Und da haben wir dann gleich schon was mitgebracht, um das mal zu erproben, oder?
17 Clips Christian Lindner.
Bis alle wütend rausrennen.
Bis wir die Revolution gestartet haben. Wir gucken, wie lange durchgehalten wird.
Okay, und wer das nachhören will, wie diese Revolution dann verlaufen ist, kann das tun.
Die Folge ist dann ab jetzt für die Sanonisten hörbar und buchbar,
ist das ja bekanntermaßen über Patreon und Apple.
Wir aber präferieren Steady und wir freuen uns dann, wenn ihr den Live-Salon so miterleben könnt.
Mit erleben könnt und vielleicht sehen wir uns ja dann bald auch mal leibhaftig in Frankfurt.
Sehr gut, bis gleich! Bis gleich!